There's a phrase that lots of the most extreme
and radical religious right Republicans will
pull out for special occasions when they really
want to go off the deep end. And that phrase is
the mark of the beast. And Republican
Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor Green
is pulling that phrase out as a
reference to vaccine passports. Now,
a little background first on Mark of the
Beast. Mark of the Beast is a symbol in
the Book of Revelation in the Bible. It has four
or five different interpretations, depending on
which sect of Christianity you are part of. Let's
look at the clip first and I'll explain the way
that Marjorie Taylor Green is using the phrase
mark of the beast here. OK, let's take a look.
They want you to be required to have something
called a covid passport. And this this would
mandate your ability to be able to travel,
your ability to be able to go to events,
your ability to be able to buy and sell.
And I asked the question earlier today,
is this something like Biden's mark of the beast?
Because that is really disturbing and not good.
Oh, if you're going to come in to the football
game or the baseball game or the concert,
you need your vaccine passport, because we're
trying to do a good job to keep everyone safe.
This is what the Biden administration is trying
to talk to these private companies and doing well,
let's say analyze that. You see, it's still the
same thing. It's still fascism or communism,
whatever you want to call it. But it's and it's
coming from private companies. So I have a term
for that. I call it corporate communism.
I love that at the end it's fascism or
communism or whatever you want to call it, even
if those are two completely different things,
call it whatever, whatever it is, whatever you
want to call it, that's what we're against.
Now, the relevant definition here for Mark of
the Beast is from some fundamentalist Christian
groups who interpret the mark of the beast as a
requirement for commerce to mean that the mark
might be an object with the function of like a
credit card or an I.D., an RFID microchip implant.
Like a decade ago on the show, I interviewed some
fundamental right wing Christian who said that
RFID chipping that's starting to
appear in different consumer products
is the mark of the beast. That's the the sort
of umbrella, the universe of interpretation of
Mark of the Beast that she's using. Some of
these groups believe that the implementation
of chips may be the imprinting of the mark
of the beast, and this would be a prophesied
requirement for trade as a precursor to
God's wrath. So anyway, in this case,
the vaccine passport is that mark of the
beast, that requirement for commerce of sorts.
I don't want to dig too far into the other
religious interpretations of Mark of the Beast,
because each of them applies only to like a small
percentage of Christians and Christians are. Just
a portion of Americans and Americans are just a
portion of all world citizens who believe this
mark of the beast stuff. I want to focus on
the silliness of focusing in on the vaccine
passport as some evil thing when it comes to covid
vaccines. And there's a lot of people who have
been tweeting about this and they seem ignorant
to the fact that they even participate in. And
I'll give you examples. Donald Trump Jr. has
been tweeting similarly about vaccine passports,
not religiously based. He tweeted, for example,
quote, Don't let them turn America into China.
Vaccine passports are a serious threat to American
civil liberties. Another example from Don Jr. who
tweeted, Vaccine passports. Communist China
would be proud of the Democrat's recent push.
His kids and most kids go to schools that require
vaccines. It's just not been the covid vaccine
for now, although we are already seeing colleges
who are saying you need a covid vaccine to come
back to campus. Those same colleges have had
other vaccine requirements for a long time. When
I went to summer camp, I needed proof of certain
vaccinations. When I went to college, I needed to
go and get a physical and I needed to get certain
vaccines and have proof that I had those vaccines.
This is not new. This is not controversial. It's
no more controversial when it's this vaccine
instead of others. Some people will say,
David, this is like requiring a flu shot.
It's really not in the sense that the covid death
rate unvaccinated is way higher than the flu death
rate unvaccinated. So to make it I don't know
why we would be talking about that. Vaccines
are required already to do all sorts of different
things, including going presumably to the schools
that Don Jr.'s kids go to. Maybe he doesn't know.
Maybe he's not involved in their schooling. I have
no idea. But the idea that this is somehow
different because covid is newer is very,
very silly. They won't stop with this
stuff. They're focused in UNcancel culture.
They're focused in on debt and deficit because
Biden wants to do infrastructure and all these
different things and they're focused in on vaccine
passports right now. Just don't fall for it. Don't
fall for it. There's nothing controversial about
it whatsoever, I would imagine. What? Ninety,
ninety, ninety five. Ninety nine percent of
the people talking about vaccine passports have
either themselves or kids that had required
vaccinations, which they got period wasn't
controversial. They're not even talking
about it. Maybe they're not even aware of it.